bienvenidos a la am al vídeo de
pendientes este es el vídeo de
pendientes y vamos a iniciar con esto
entonces lo que voy a hacer aquí es pues
nos vamos a tal vez no tengas algún
breve estudio sobre las pendientes o
tengas la intuición de lo que es una
pendiente
entonces lo que voy a hacer es para
tener una recta y calcular su pendiente
necesitamos dos puntos cierto porque por
dos puntos pasa una recta entonces qué
te parece si voy a elegir algunos puntos
que te parece el punto menos 13 menos 13
entonces voy a graficar ese punto aquí
está el 0 0 aquí está el menos 1 lo
escribo este es menos menos 1 y después
3 para arriba sería 1 2 3 aquí está el
punto entonces ese estrés y aquí está el
punto menos 13 ahora vamos con el
siguiente punto necesitamos dos puntos
para tener una recta que pasa por ellos
entonces qué te parece
el punto 21 entonces sería dos espacios
a la derecha uno dos y después uno para
arriba
este es el dos y uno para arriba aquí
está el punto 2,1 ahora que ya tenemos
los dos puntos necesitamos una una recta
que los conectes cierto entonces voy a
trazar una recta
como desde aquí pero no creo que no es
una muy buena técnica mejor inicio de un
punto ok voy a iniciar aquí y que pase
por el otro punto es creo que es una
mejor técnica para que pase por los dos
puntos y no no no será cierto esto ahí
está y ahora ya solo la prolongó muy
bien entonces ahí está la recta ya
tenemos entonces lo que necesitábamos
para tener una pendiente de una recta
tenemos dos puntos por ahí pasa pasa una
recta y puedes ver qué que está esta
recta tiene una inclinación cierto
entonces creo que tal vez de cierta
manera ya tengas idea de lo que es una
pendiente la pendiente de una recta esta
inclinación
y va de izquierda bueno baja de
izquierda superior a derecha inferior
entonces puedes notar que que se inclina
hacia abajo entonces nos dará un número
negativo y es algo bueno se ve así a
simple vista entonces lo escribo y
escribo pendiente ok entonces bueno la
variable que esto es la pendiente es
igual a m no sé por qué se usa m porque
mejor p no pero no se usa la m
no tengo idea de por qué razón pero es
igual a al cambio en yes sobre el cambio
en x donde esté este triangulito es la
letra delta en griego y significa cambio
ahora esto es igual a la elevación sobre
el avance entonces primero vamos con con
este punto del menos 13 cuánto será
cuánto será la elevación y cuánto será
el avance para llegar a este otro punto
amarillo el punto 2 1 primero vamos con
la elevación es menos 2 cierto porque
estamos bajando 2 espacios para llegar a
la misma llevó a la misma altura en la
que está el punto 2 1 entonces la
elevación es igual a menos 2 bajamos los
espacios para llegar a la misma y cuánto
será el avance el avance estrés positivo
cierto entonces la elevación sobre el
avance es igual a menos 2 sobre 3 es
igual a menos 2 sobre 3
aquí tenemos esta gráfica que nos ayuda
a ver todo muy bonito pero y si no
tuviéramos que qué haríamos tomaríamos
primero a este a este primer punto este
sería nuestro punto de partida
entonces tendríamos el cambio en yes
sobre el cambio en x eso es igual a
tomar a la primera entrada y entonces
ten tomamos a 3 y le restamos menos 1
bajar solo lo que hice fue tomar este
este 3 y a este 1 y restar los son las
coordenadas bueno las entradas se niegue
sobre menos 1 la primera entrada en x
menos la segunda entrada en x que es 2
entonces menos 2 a que es igual esto 3
menos uno es igual a dos y menos uno
menos dos es igual a menos tres
obtuvimos lo mismo cierto esto es igual
a menos dos sobre tres o lo podemos lo
pudimos haber hecho de la otra manera
también pudimos haber iniciado con con
este punto con este punto
y si hubiéramos hecho eso entonces el
cambio en que hubiera sido sería el
cambio en esta primera y uno menos tres
sobre el cambio en x que sería 2 - menos
1 entonces hacemos uno menos 3 es igual
a menos 2 y 2 menos menos 1 es igual a 3
obtenemos lo mismo menos dos tercios así
que como puedes ver no importa con qué
número iniciamos cierto si usamos la y
en esta coordenada primero debemos usar
la la equis en esa coordenada también
primero hagamos unos ejercicios más para
dejar en claro esto de la pendiente y de
hecho no voy a usar no los voy a
graficar vamos a hacer el álgebra para
que veas a qué me refiero con todo esto
entonces vamos a decidir supongamos que
tenemos dos puntos el 52 y el
35 vamos a iniciar con el 35 primero
como punto de inicio entonces el cambio
en yes sobre el cambio en x es igual a 5
este 5 menos 2
sobre el cambio y nye que es igual a 3
menos 5 y esto esto es igual a 5 menos
dos igual a tres y este es un 53 menos 5
es igual a menos 2 eso es igual a menos
tres medios y ya está entonces vamos a
hacer más ejemplos y voy a usar colores
para codificar entonces tomamos al punto
12 y al punto
43 el punto 4 3
entonces la pendiente es igual a cambio
en 10 sobre cambio en x pendiente es
igual a cambio en
cambio en yes sobre cambio en x el
cambio y llevamos a tomar primero al
ayer iniciamos con con este punto ajá
entonces llamemos a esa y de 1 así que
el cambio es igual a 3 - este estalle
que es 2 entonces 3 - 2 sobre el cambio
en x que es igual
a esta a esta primera x 4 - la segunda
x1 entonces 4 menos uno y tenemos tres
menos 2 sobre 4 menos 13 menos 2 es
igual a 1 y 4 menos uno es igual a 3 así
que un tercio la pendiente es es un
tercio y pudimos haber iniciado de la
otra manera también pudimos haberlo
hecho de la de la otra forma donde
tomamos primero al 2 restamos 32 menos 3
sobre
14 sobre 1 menos 4 y esto es igual 2
menos tres es igual a menos 1 y 1 menos
4 es igual a menos 3 lo cual es lo mismo
que un tercio de ese es lo mismo
entonces piensa porque esto y esto es
exactamente lo mismo piensen porque es
exactamente lo mismo pero lo importante
es darse cuenta que usamos al 3 primero
si usamos al 3 primero también debemos
usar al 4 primero en ese mismo punto
ahora es algo con lo que las personas
suelen equivocarse al calcular y también
las leyes de los signos son muy
importantes no no te vayas a equivocar
con las leyes de los signos aprenden de
las bien ahora en el próximo vídeo vamos
a ver la la ecuación de una recta de
igual a mx + b donde m es la pendiente
de la recta y b es la intersección de la
ordenada y entonces bueno si conoces
esos dos datos ya prácticamente conoces
toda la recta y puedes calcular
cualquier punto en esa recta entonces
inténtalo diviértete con con esto de las
pendientes y nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo así que bueno bye